يوفنتوس يبحثون عن الفوز دائما ولكن في
نابولي مدينه مارادونا هناك بحث عن جماليه
كره القدم هذه هي الطريقه التي تحيا بها
المدينه هنا بهذه الكلمات وصف لوتشينوس
اختلاف رحلته في نابولي عن صادق رحلاته
وكيف وجد اخيرا تلك الخلطه بين رؤيته لكره
القدم ورؤيه النادي الذي يدربه
وترى فيها تقاليد الكره الكلاسيكيه تلك
التي ما زالت تقدس مشاهده الملعب من
المدرجات وهز الحناجر طوال المباراه
بتشجيعات صاخبه ولكنهم يشجعون ابناء
الجنوب الذين لا تضحك لهم الحياه كثيرا
فقط هناك معجزه حدثت ابانا الحقبه
التاريخيه لديغو مارادونا ومنذ عام 1990
يحلمون بتكرار الحلم المشترك بين نابولي
لوسباليد اجتمع على هدف واحد وهو لقب
الدوري ذلك الغائب عن ابناء الجنوب منذ 33
عاما والمؤجل في قلب سبالتي منذ بدايه
مسيرته في اول كلماته بعد الفوز بلقب
السكوديتو
احدى الانجاز لشقيقه الراحل الذي توفي قبل
اربع سنوات حيث قال اهدي هذا اللقب لشقيق
مارتشيلو قبل ان ابدا مسيره التدريبيه قلت
انني سوف اهدف للفوز بالسكوديتوا فسخر مني
الجميع اما هو فسندني والان لقد فعلتها
لقد جعلت شعب نابولي سعداء انه شعور لا
يوصف مسيره سباليتي التدريبيه بدات في عام
1990 قبل رحيل مارادونا عن بولي بعام واحد
ومنذ ذلك الحين يحلم هو بلقب الاسكوديتو
كما اخبر اخيه الراحل ويحلم عشاقنا بوني
بتكرار معجزه مارادونا التي حضرها بعضهم
وعاش الاخرون على حكايتها مع الامل في
رؤيتها يوما ما سنوات مرت وفقدت وظيفته
متهما بالفشل في مرات كثيره وهبط نابولي
الى الدرجه الثانيه وانهار قبل ان يعود
بدايه العقد الماضي سنوات كان فيها
سباليتسي ونابولي قريبان من تحقيق الاوسكي
ديتو ولكنهما سقطا في اخر المشوار فضلت
حكايتهما رساله امل لهما ول بان يحاولوا
مره اخرى وفي النهايه قد تبتسم كره القدم
سبالاتصال وجالات ايطاليا ونجح في احداث
طفره في اودنز وروما ويضع بدايه مشروع
انتر واهتزت نهايه كرحله اخرى فيدوريا
وتجربه ثانيه في روما ولكنه كان دوما صاحب
فكر مختلف الاختلاف الذي جعله متهما دوما
اما بجنون او بالفشل وفي الرابعه وستين من
عمره يحقق الحلم الذي اخبر به اخيه يحقق
لوس كوديتول الذي راهن عليه في شبابه
ويصبح اكبر مدربين في تاريخه بعمر 64 عاما
و58 يوما ويسعد شعبنا بولين متعطش لتكرار
قصه دييغو ورفاقه ليجتمع اطفال وشباب
واصحاب الشعر الابيض على فرحه جنونيه في
مدينه تتنفس الفن وكره القدم هذه التوليفه
حدثت نتيجه ماراها عليه هذه المره بانه في
نابولي مدينه مارادونا هناك بحث عن
جماليات كره القدم قد اتفق مع جنونه في
كره القدم التي يلعبها استحداث جديده كما
فعل بيبي غوارديولا بعد ذلك ولكن المشهد
الاخير ابى ان يبتسم الاسباليتي في كل
رحلاته مع الكبار في روما وانترا وقرر ان
يبتسم في اكثر قصه تشبهه حيث جماليه كره
القدم قبل اي شيء اخر وحيث الفنون والجنون
ومرضنا ونفس النظره الفلسفيه للحياه فتحقق
الحلم بالشكل السينمائي الذي يتفق مع رؤيه
كليهما للحياه وهكذا كان المشهد الاخير
الافضل للكره الايطاليه في موسم 2023
بعنوان نابولي بطل الدوري الايطالي